Jaku Yue
[Music]
Ah ah Timin
Marisa, I called me. It's a
glare. It's possible to be able to get it over.
Thank you for all your efforts, Marisa
[Music]
A n The airport is in the opposite lane After all,
Gacchi is the one who is making it. In the end,
I can't do
anything but wait. When something happens in the distance,
I'm scared to see that girl, so I cry out.  I couldn't hang it. I
should have snuggled up to you. Come
here!
Even I know that Narumi is passive. Of course, I'm fully aware that it's a parasol. Haha, it's
New Year's Day with seven egg guns, after all.
Bridge Loa.
[Music] Look,
are we also a reward?
Seriously, I
confused my name with Iga. I've
become stronger, Kanatame.